- I think I still need to do my taxes,
is it April 15th that --
- It's April 15th, but if you mail them,
then it's gonna take a while
so you gotta do it like --
- I'm Milo, that's Moe, and this is Paul,
our fun-loving and not-as-responsible
best friend and roommate.
He's also two years younger
than the both of us,
and it shows.
Paul!
(lighthearted music)
He knows about new stuff on
the internet way before we do.
- What is Damn Daniel?
- It's a meme.
- What the hell is a meme?
- Can't explain a meme.
- What?
- [Milo] And knows nothing about
real-world stuff that matters.
- Did you even file your taxes, man?
- No.
- Are you going to?
- Do I need to?
- Short answer: yes,
long answer: yes, Paul.
File your taxes.
God love him.
I mean he really just doesn't know.
- What even is a 401(k)?
- [Milo] Sometimes he does
stuff that I find immature.
Come on guys.
- [Paul] What floor are we going to?
- [Moe] Four.
- I think it's the fourth.
No! Paul, why would you --
- [Paul] I'm having fun, I dunno.
- [Milo] And he has way more energy
than me and Moe combined.
I mean the boy can skate all day.
All day!
Moe tends to treat him
like a little brother.
- All I'm saying is that at some point
you're gonna like a girl,
she might like you back.
- I like playing girls.
- [Milo] But it's because
he's still so youthful.
Can I get a coffee?
- Yeah, let me get a cappuccino.
- Orange soda for me, please.
- [Milo] Speaking of, he hates
being treated like a baby.
- That's kinda how it works, young bull.
Little man with a plan (laughs).
Grow up, Peter Pan.
- Okay, can you stop it?
- I'm just saying.
- [Milo] But we are the only
ones allowed to baby him.
- I don't think so, little guy (laughs)
- Hey man, don't talk to him like that.
- Yeah, don't do that.
- I'm so sorry, I didn't--
- You okay?
- Yeah.
- [Milo] Sometimes my
girlfriends are into him
and that is weird.
- So tell me about Paul, is he single?
- Oh girl, he is a baby.
But it's not bad being the youngest,
you've got your whole
life ahead of you and
people are gonna look out for you.
Well, at least your friends will.
(lighthearted music)